salut à tous ici envergure et voici le
deuxième épisode de notre format spécial
draft 2023 et surtout spécial Victor
wembanyama une fois par mois on va
suivre la progression de celui qu'on
attend pour être la prochaine star du
basketball français on va la suivre avec
beaucoup de précisions va aussi parler
de l'actualité de ses concurrents à la
draft NBA de ce qui pourrait pourquoi
pas tenter de lui voler la place de
numéro 1 en tout cas être dans la Green
Room avec lui le soir de la draft Victor
et les autres notre podcast l'épisode 2
c'est parti le père aimait Hugo ils
prennent la main Victor ce fils dont le
destin d'effraya les gazettes
[Musique]
c'est tous les deux votre première dans
un podcast donc ça fait plaisir et puis
FD qui avec nous salut FD salut Alex
effectivement c'est c'est la première
c'est mon stade mon stade de Rouky
exactement et bien et bien bonne
première à vous deux on attaque tout de
suite la première partie elle est news
dans le monde de Victor que vais-je
trouver d'abord
messieurs les news
en gros qu'est-ce que vous retenez du
mois écoulé qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué
on avait enregistré le dernier épisode
et on l'avait sorti juste avant les
matchs de Boulogne Levallois face à
ligue night donc les matchs à Las Vegas
dans lesquels Victor a Brié Yassine
qu'est-ce que tu retiens je retiens
beaucoup de choses déjà que la hype elle
a triplé les mondial maintenant depuis
les deux matchs contre l'Algérie United
ça a vraiment pris une grosse ampleur
surtout avec la NBA qui a racheté les
droits des matchs de Victor
donc il y a beaucoup de choses qui ont
changé
et Victor répond présent que ça soit sur
le terrain et même en dehors je pense
pas qu'il est pris la grosse tête les
tours souriants donc voilà FD ouais
monter en puissance monter en puissance
médiatique mais surtout sur le terrain
je trouve qu'ils prend beaucoup plus ses
ssses dans dans le collectif de Boulogne
Levallois
il comprend maintenant il a eu cette
première phase d'expérimentation au
début de saison où il a essayé il a pris
des risques il a essayé des nouvelles
choses et maintenant il comprend ce qui
est ce qui est efficace
et il commence à devenir un joueur avec
moins de déchets et cette raison cette
prise en puissance individuelle lui
permet vraiment de de faire des énormes
performances en ce moment mais j'aime
bien aussi puisqu'il est plus en
confiance dans le collectif en ce moment
je le trouve un peu plus altruiste et je
vois sur cette dernière match où
notamment notamment quand
Bourg-en-Bresse et contre Limoges il
essaie de beaucoup plus compliqué c'est
coéquipiers et là où avant il prenait
beaucoup de tirs compliqués au poste
maintenant il va chercher il va chercher
ses coéquipiers dans dans l'altruisme ça
je trouve que c'est une très bonne
évolution il va chercher les lancer
francs aussi c'est par rapport à ses
premiers matchs je sais pas ce que tu en
penses mais il va il va il va provoquer
un peu plus de fautes peut-être jouer un
peu plus au contact ouais ouais je pense
que notamment
l'expérience Diligen Night et notamment
le premier carton du premier match où il
a eu un petit peu de mal au poste face
au poste 5 de David Guy night qui était
qui était très physique ou il a pas
réussi à l'enfoncer
un petit peu moins de tirs compliquée au
poste c'est effectivement un petit peu
plus de mouvement vers le panier ça va
lui donner des fautes ça va le forcer
aussi à faire des kick-up de temps en
temps et je trouve qu'il le fait mieux
il aurait pu le faire un petit peu plus
tôt dans la saison mais là il a commencé
à vouloir impliquer ses coéquipiers et
c'est positif et encore du déchet mais
c'est positif là où il a aussi pris en
agressivité au niveau du robot offensif
je le trouve plus actif au rebond
offensif et sa longueur forcément l'aide
à gober c'est rebond mais une fois qu'il
a chopé le ballon je le trouve que je
trouve qu'il va plus au cercle et
effectivement un petit peu plus de
contact
Yassine tu les as vu les matchs de des
métropolitanes
à la jellye Guy night qui qu'est-ce qui
t'a marqué dans le jeu cette fois tout à
l'heure tu disais voilà hype mondial à
une vieille qui rachète les droits etc
vraiment dans le jeu qui est comment
Victor t'a marqué pendant ces deux
matchs mais il m'a marqué parce que les
moi je le trouve altruiste il a pas
cherché à vouloir prouver il a laissé le
jeu venir à lui et c'est ce qui a fait
qu'il a performé il n'a pas été vraiment
de tout être à vouloir tirer à trois
points prouver que il peut le faire il a
essayé de jouer un peu partout et ça a
fonctionné après il y a beaucoup tir à
trois plombs mais avec réussite quoi
aussi surtout le premier match vous avez
vraiment impressionné mais je trouve que
c'est c'est venu à lui c'est pas lui qui
est venu qui a cherché car il essayait
de d'en faire trop
c'est ça que j'ai aimé aussi chez lui
c'est vrai nous on va passer à la
deuxième partie messieurs
[Musique]
deuxième partie donc on va parler si
vous le voulez bien de la protection de
cercle de Victor et alors là on va
vraiment rentrer dans le détail donc on
va essayer de d'être un petit peu précis
on va commencer par toi FD j'aimerais
que tu me parles des déplacements
défensifs de Victor ce qui a de bon ce
qu'il y a de moins bon ce qui a ce qu'il
y a à travailler et comment on peut
imaginer ça évoluer dans un contexte NBA
on parle des déplacements défensifs
notamment pour protéger le cercle
puisque c'est le thème la protection de
cercle alors sur ces déplacements la
première chose à évoquer on va commencer
par par l'évidan mais pour un joueur de
sa taille il a une mobilité qui est qui
est anormale voilà ça c'est la première
chose mais il faut il faut quand même la
il faut quand même poser les évidences
au départ
[Musique]
il a il a une mobilité qui coupait en
fait à sa longueur fait qui peut couvrir
énormément de terrain en très peu de
temps et ça lui permet
même s'il a des des largesses au niveau
de ses prises d'appui de ses
orientations de hanche
ça lui permet de gommer ces
erreurs parce qu'il est très long et
parce qu'il peut avoir un petit un petit
burst qui lui qui lui permet d'avoir une
zone de manœuvre qui est très très
grande en fait
là où je pense qu'il y a vraiment des
progrès à faire c'est notamment au
niveau du pick and roll on parlera après
de ses couvertures mais quand il défend
en drop il a une orientation des hanches
qui lui permet pas de réagir très
rapidement ou en tout cas pas de suivre
l'attaquant ou de rester devant lui donc
ça c'est c'est quelque chose qui va
falloir travailler je pense pour lui
c'est cette rotation des hanches de
manière à pouvoir accompagner
l'attaquant et pas prendre un retard dès
les premiers appuis voilà ça c'est c'est
ce qui a un petit peu à travailler
mais sinon dans l'ensemble les
déplacements sont bons et ils sont
suffisants pour pouvoir accompagner
l'attaquant jusqu'au cercle ou en tout
cas pouvoir contester grâce à sa
longueur
yes
est-ce que tu peux me parler de ces
aptitudes à contrer et
principalement de ces aptitudes
physiques puisque encore une fois on
rentre dans le détail donc est-ce qu'il
saute vraiment très haut et ce qui
utilise sa longueur et ce qui sautent
rapidement et ce qui saute dans le bon
tempo bref est-ce qu'il est bon au
contre que ce soit au contre sur son
adversaire directe ou au contre quand on
va sur un autre joueur pour moi c'est
une de ces grandes qualités le contre
que ce soit au périmètre ou proche du
cercle
il saut haut
grâce à ça à longueur je pense pas qu'il
saute vraiment rond mais il est
tellement long que ici là il a pas trop
besoin de sauter
[Musique]
c'est il modifie les attaques adverses
je pense que les jours en face le crime
surtout proche du cercle parce que c'est
demain sont actives voilà en plus il
ambidextre c'est pas de Nat tout le
monde franchement c'est adversaires
on parlait FD tu mentionnel pick and
roll tout à l'heure peut-être aller un
peu plus loin là-dessus mais
est-ce que toi tu tu penses que il y a
une couverture idéale ou est-ce que il
sait tout faire tu disais qu'en drop il
était un peu moins bon mais quel est
quelle est ta vision des choses sur les
couvertures de Pick & roll de Victor
comment il est utilisé cette année à par
les métropolitanes et comment il
pourrait être utilisé en NBA ouais alors
sur l'utilisation en piquant je dirais
pas que le drop est une faiblesse mais
je vais y revenir ils ont commencé
surtout en drop le premier match contre
Gravelines Dunkerque c'était énormément
de drop avec un espèce de oui ou de
victoire défendait en dessous du niveau
de l'écran donc en drop il y avait
aucune volonté de changer avec le
défenseur du du garde qui passait au
dessus et donc le job de Victor était
juste de d'empêcher l'accès au cercle
en attendant que le garde revienne sur
sur le sur le porteur de balle
c'était pas non plus un drop super
profond quand on peut le voir en NBA
avec des équipes comme Milwaukee ou
Youtube avec du rudy Gobert ou vraiment
on attendait dans la raquette non c'est
plus tôt à peu à peine en dessous du
niveau de l'écran donc Victor pouvait
quand même contester les tirs à trois
points c'est ça le la grande la grande
force de Victor et c'est une force qui
est vraiment inédite pour le coup
beaucoup donc de joueurs que je regarde
c'est même en drop même en drop il est
capable d'altérer un tir à trois points
qui qui serait pris par par le garde en
sortie d'écran parce que même en
contenant le drive il est capable
d'avoir un effet sur le pull-up donc ça
c'est il y a quelques situations où il
est en drop mais il arrive quand même à
contrer le tir à trois points et ça
c'est un atout qui sera super utile même
en NBA maintenant au au fur et à mesure
de la saison on a vu les métropolysan
varient un petit peu leur couverture
depuis kenrol
notamment sur les postes 2-3 quand c'est
des postes de 3 qui prennent les écrans
on n'hésite pas à changer voilà sur les
derniers matchs face à Bourg face à face
à Blois on a vu Victor changer sur des
postes de Troyes et bah ça se passe bien
en fait ça se passe bien
il y a très peu de situations où il est
vraiment pris de vitesse et j'en ai
presque pas vu
là où il a un petit peu de mal c'est
face au changement de direction rapide
et face aux femmes de tir mais mais sur
sur switch il y a pas il y a pas trop de
soucis non plus il y a eu très peu de
situations où il a switché sur des
postes 1 ou sur des postes très rapides
mais même là il suffit qu'ils prennent
un ou deux pas de recul qui laisse un
petit peu plus de place et qui qui force
le poste 1 à tiré au-dessus de lui et en
fait c'est très rare parce que ce que
disait Yassine sur cette cette peur de
Victor Wayne bagnah on le voit aussi sur
la couverture de pic and roll sur le
premier match ça grave une Dunkerque il
y avait vraiment cette impression que
Victor était ciblée qui voulait ils ont
fait énormément de piquets de rôle sur
lui ils ont beaucoup joué face à son
drop en fait ça a pas beaucoup
fonctionné et maintenant on se retrouve
avec beaucoup d'équipes qui justement ne
veulent pas impliquer Victory donc
laisse son attaquant dans le corner pour
éviter
du ballon sur des phases d'attaques donc
si je te suis
on va peut-être l'utiliser alors eux ils
appellent pas ils ont une nuance sur le
drop les Américains en termes de
vocabulaire pour un peu expliquer quand
même aux auditeurs ils appellent ça le
contain c'est quand tu fais pas
totalement du drop à la rudy Gobert mais
mais quand tu es quand même au dessus du
niveau de l'écran au moment où le joueur
prend l'écran quoi oui oui mais là où ça
va peut-être poser problème si l'écran
est posé très haut parce qu'on voit en
NBA que les écrans sont posés
sont posés sont posées plus haut quand
quand betclicalic il faut voilà on
imagine le cliché c'est un peu Damien
leelhart quoi de poser des écrans très
très haut c'est là où Victor a un petit
peu de mal puisque sur un sur une
défense de contain
il va être il va être du coup un contrat
face à des garde et c'est là s'il y a si
le porteur de balle change très
rapidement de direction et comment son
rêve c'est là qu'il a un petit peu de
mal parce que le défense enfin Victor
est arrêté l'attaquant arrive déjà avec
un petit peu de vitesse avec un
changement de rythme là il peut prendre
il peut prendre l'avantage sur Victor
c'est là où il y a eu quelques quelques
cas notamment le fils le fils de John
Stockton pour ceux qui savaient pas
jouer
deux trois fois il a pris l'avantage là
dessus parce que Victor est un petit peu
un petit peu sur les talons un peu
flatfoutis et du coup se fait surprendre
sur un changement de direction et perd
son duel donc attention voilà sur le
contain oui si les écrans sont posés un
petit peu haut attention à l'espace quoi
attention il se passe qu'il y a derrière
oui tu disais placement des appuis
oui c'est ça c'est ça c'est
l'orientation initiale des appuis
qui qui pour l'instant est pas est pas
optimal quoi c'est là qu'il a perdu le
plupart de ses duré Yacine
est-ce que tu peux tu peux parler de de
comment tu le tu le vois défendre toi un
NBA
[Musique]
oh pas proche du cercle
les aides il les fait il les fait pas
bien
il sort pas assez vite alors que les
proches du cercle ben là il a plus
facile c'est pour ça que c'est la
plupart de ces blocs sont proches du
cercle
et donc moi je pense que niveau de la
lecture du jeu
quand il a un peu haut il a encore des
difficultés surtout quand ça quand il
les fasse à des meneurs rapides
par exemple lors d'un picken run
il a du mal comme on parlait au début
avec sert la rotation de hanche il a
encore du mal à se retourner se retourne
pas assez vite et les prix souvent
donc voilà moi je pense qu'il est encore
du travail à faire sur ça sur la
réactive la réactivité voilà alors
évidemment ce qui écoute on coupe les
cheveux en 4 c'est le but de ce podcast
[Musique]
FD l'a dit au début et Yassine aussi
prospect défensif et potentiel défensif
immense du côté de de Victor wembania ma
FD est-ce que tu as un truc à ajouter à
sa protection de cercle donc que tu
aurais pu
il faut pour les pour les gens qui
l'auraient pas vu il faut bien imaginer
que ça sa protection de cercle elle est
pas forcément dans le sens dans le sens
traditionnel du terme un petit peu à la
dans la verticalité en fait à la doit à
la rainberte même à la Dream ongrid même
s'il est un petit peu plus petit ou
c'est en fait on va se passer face à
l'attaquant et on va
on va anticiper en fait et on va on va
prendre l'attaquant de quoi
Yama c'est un style de RIM protection
assez différent où il va plutôt défendre
par le côté en fait il va laisser le
porteur de balles prendre de l'avance et
il va défendre en fait une fois que le
tirer lâché voilà pour faire un contre
ou
alors juste sa dissuasion va faire que
le tir va jamais être pris
alors ça ça fonctionne pour l'instant
parce que les pourcentages de réussite
de ses adversaires au cercle en Beth
liquides sont abisseaux abyssal abysso
je sais pas
mais mais je pense que pour l'instant
c'est aussi par nécessité parce que je
sais pas si il est capable pour
l'instant de de prendre le premier
contact de prendre le contact de face et
de rester vertical en fait re liberté
très bien je suis pas sûr que Victor
Vaiana puisse le faire pour l'instant et
la deuxième nuance qui a apporté
là-dessus c'est que ça rime protection
elle est d'autant plus efficace en
France
qui peut chasser la balle une fois
qu'elle est sur l'arceau ce qui est une
règle ce qui est une règle qui n'existe
pas enfin ce qui est interdit aux
États-Unis en fait c'est un goldening
il fait beaucoup ça en fait où il a il
défend en attendant que la balle touche
le cercle et une fois que la balle
touche le serre qui est de l'enlève
c'est une partie importante de son jeu
il faut bien penser que ça ce sera gommé
une fois qu'il ira aux États-Unis
absolument et bien je crois que nous
allons fermer la page Victor web
baniyama puisque le podcast s'appelle
Victor et les autres il est temps de
parler un peu des autres
et les autres en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui c'est coûte Anderson joueur
de jilik ignate qui n'a pas encore 19
ans qui les aura en début d'année
prochaine il joue à les meneurs arrières
1m93,88 kg il était déjà en jelly big
night l'année dernière et il y a
retourné cette année c'est pour créer un
duel face à lui que les Metz sont allés
jouer à Las Vegas face à lui et aux
autres de Jilly Knight mais franchement
lui est le joueur projeté numéro 2 et si
Victor n'était pas là il serait projeté
numéro improbablement
assez largement devant les autres
membres de la CUV à raison ou à tort on
n'est pas là pour pour faire des modes
draft tout de suite
déjà Yassine il a commencé sa saison
scotonnait d'accord
[Musique]
ces points forts mais vraiment on est
sur un joueur très vif à la fois vif et
à la fois puissant en fait qui est qui
monte au cercle très facilement
évidemment qui a un gros handle mais
c'est ses qualités de base c'est voilà
rapidité bas en main capable de créer un
peu pour les autres et puis de surtout
finition très fort dans la raquette
comme est-ce qu'il a comment il a évolué
cet été par rapport à ce que tu ce que
tu dois faire l'année dernière mais
premièrement il a évolué sur sa défense
enfin surtout contre les métropolitanes
là j'ai après je sais pas si c'est parce
qu'il jouait contre Victor il voulait
prouver vraiment j'ai été sur des
séquences hépatives parce que l'année
passée c'était pas trop ça niveau
défense
leur défense au niveau au périmètre
puisque il peut défendre que les postes
un ou deux je le vois pas des fois sur
un 3
mais il est explosif rapide puissant il
défendait durement alors que l'année
passée c'était pas le cas et aussi sur
son premier match il était pas assez
régulier sur ses poules à mi distance
et je trouve que lors du premier match
il en a mis quelques-uns et franchement
c'est on a vu un progrès là-dessus
en difficulté sur sur
longue distance c'est son vraiment son
gros défaut et sur les aspects vraiment
techniques est-ce que que ce soit sur le
tiramidexistant c'est ce que tu as vu
que la gestuelle avait changé ou non ou
c'est juste la réussite sur le handle
est-ce qu'il y a de la de la progression
sur la passe est-ce qu'il y a de la
progression voilà sur les aspects
vraiment techniques les trois grands
aspects techniques offensifs avec ballon
je pense pas que pour moi ça mécanique
n'a pas changé il est plus en réussite
il tente plus aussi
après
son premier pas est toujours aussi
explosif il y a pas toujours aussi vite
il est son Haendel est très très bon ce
qu'il ce qui lui permet de
se balader et d'aller d'accéder plus
facilement au cercle il est très fort il
est très fort proche du cercle
je pense qu'il a il a évolué dans le bon
sens après il y a quelques défauts mais
on en reparlera
FD quelle impression je sais pas si tu
l'avais vu l'année dernière
quelle impression il t'a fait très très
peu
du match
contre les maths
une très bonne impression une très bonne
impression c'est vrai que c'était un peu
resté sur l'idée d'un
de quelqu'un qui était constamment dans
le drive alors très agressif très
athlétique mais un peu toujours toujours
sur une vitesse quoi et c'est vrai que
cette première possession où il prend un
pick and roll et il prend un très bon
poulet à 1200 ça je me suis dit ah ouais
il y a peut-être un petit peu plus que
juste un
uber athlète initiateur quoi et c'est
vrai que
il y a ce disait qu'il y avait cette ce
développement au niveau du du midrain je
pense que c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui va être
décisif pour lui
puisque sur le pire je l'ai trouvé
vraiment très patient pour le coup sur
ce match de Gilly enfin de face au Mas
pardon je l'ai trouvé très patient je
trouvais que il prenait il prenait le
temps de voir des lectures et je pense
que ça va vraiment l'aider dans son
premier mais qui
et honnêtement de tous les de tout j'ai
regardé tous les matchs de Victor cette
année c'est le garde qui a mieux à ta
fin qui a le mieux attaqué sur Victor au
Cercle parce qu'il est capable d'aller
au contact donc c'est le contact est
terminé après mais aussi de faire des
finitions acrobatiques et de finir
autour de Victor Hugo c'est le seul que
j'ai vu faire ça sur l'ensemble du film
que j'ai regardé alors c'est une bonne
chose qui soit meilleur que des que des
meneurs de Betclic élite et mais
vraiment voilà dans dans le drive dans
l'impact qui m'a il m'a vraiment
impressionné et puis j'ai vraiment aimé
par rapport à ce que je disais en dit au
début j'ai beaucoup aimé le contrôle qui
est dégagé quoi il y a eu très peu de
situations je me suis dit là il va trop
vite pour lui non j'ai trouvé vraiment
un contrôle hier si tu parlais des
points à améliorer pour lui qu'est-ce
que tu qu'est-ce que tu espères voir de
mieux cette année par rapport au premier
match là que tu as noté parler du tiers
extérieur mais ce que tu vois là tu peux
développer moi son premier le premier
point à développer c'est son caractère
c'est vraiment son défaut d'ailleurs son
premier match ils ont joué contre au
Cloud OMA City il a même pas appris un
tir il a pas pris un tir à trois points
il n'est pas encore en confiance
et ça c'est une arme qui ferait beaucoup
de bien dans son dans son jeu je trouve
après ça se développe il est encore
jeune
est un peu moins fou il
utilise trop le il aime beaucoup draguer
grâce à son premier pas mais des fois il
devrait un peu plus même si pour moi il
crie déjà pour les autres mais il doit
plus le faire
encore progresser ça c'est sûr
c'était pas encore son équipe
et je pense que cette année c'est
vraiment c'est l'huile
le vrai le prospect numéro 1 le meilleur
joueur et je pense qu'ils vont jouer
pour lui
on va essayer de le mettre en avant
et franchement je le vois ou dans cette
race
bah oui il est projeté numéro 2 pour toi
c'est mérité de derrière Victor quand
même mais un peu au dessus des autres je
veux pas prononcer parce que les autres
je les ai pas encore vu si tu as vu les
tomes
exactement Thomson mais
je te laisse répondre à cette question
j'ai pas encore vu assez de meuf pour
savoir les autres prospects
quand c'est pas je préfère pas parler
c'est très bien c'est exactement ce
qu'on fait envergure quand on sait pas
on dit pas même si là c'est un pronostic
sans sans égratignure FD il y a une
classe d'écart entre lui et Victor comme
dit pas encore vu pas encore assez vu
scout
maintenant voilà je pense que sur le sur
le profil c'est compliqué de se
rapprocher du temps voilà mais parce que
parce que Victor est très haut à quel
point à quel point scout et haut je ne
sais pas mais je pense qu'il est quand
même en dessous vu comment je donne de
la valeur à victoire
très bien et bien messieurs merci merci
Yassine merci avec Merci à VOUS Anthony
bien sûr toute l'année sur envergure.co
pour parler overtime Gilly ging night on
va suivre les progrès de scout mais
également de Sidi notre frenchy en night
même si là il a pas trop joué un peu ses
premiers matchs et puis la NBA il y a
toujours des prospects qui sortent de de
cette ligue australienne merci FD merci
Alex merci Yacine on retrouve on se
retrouve sur sur les peut-être les
twitchs bientôt sur twitch ouais sur
twitch pour pour épauler ce bon HUG et
puis j'espère très vite à l'écrit aussi
et puis pôle vidéo puisque vous pouvez
vous abonner évidemment notre chaîne
YouTube si vous êtes en train de nous
écouter sur youtube ou quelconque
plateforme de podcast sans monnaie sur
toutes les plateformes possibles et imag
nous allons passer à la dernière partie
et nous allons switcher à l'anglais
c'est parti avec le scout des pélicans
allez on passe en anglais comme
d'habitude pour la dernière partie de ce
podcast là-dessus tout English
NBA Austin Green Scott food pellicaine
[Musique]
voilà cette victoire et les autres
épisodes du mois de novembre sur
envergure on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour parler de cet
extraterrestre en attendant on est tous
les vendredis sur twitch la chaîne
twitch d'envergure pour évaluer les
jeunes joueurs en live avec de la vidéo
du film et puis on sort un nouveau
format podcast pour parler des roues qui
NBA dès la semaine prochaine restez
branché donc abonnez-vous à envergure
allez sur notre site voir les fiches de
joueurs les scouting report mettez-nous
des notes suivez-nous pour toutes les
news évaluations documentées des futurs
stars du basket mondial ciao tout le
monde